En riktigt omodern, gammal produkt som inte funkar.
Och vi har en lösning på en världsunik produkt som kommer att förändra det här.
Det är bara fakta.
Och vem blir först, vem gör det bäst?
För det kommer bara att vara twistbox.
Ge numret och vi kommer att göra det bäst.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt den under 60 minuter.
Jag är ju Chernobyl-generationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har reda i en bra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig, och det finns inga tvinga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Då välkomnar vi Mikael Nelderup från Twistboxes till podden, och Mikael, kanske fler av er känner igen för att han var med på Draknästet och gjorde en liten impression där.
Jag tror att det är många som såg de här Twistboxes, och tänkte, fan, det var ju smart liksom.
Det kändes väldigt logiskt när han väl såg det.
Välkommen till podden Mikael, och kan du inte bara ge oss en liten förklaring av vad det är du har tagit fram egentligen?
Ja tackar jag, tackar jag.
En ära att vara här.
Mikael Läldrup, är väl en problemlösare, det är precis vad jag vaktmäster kan kalla mig, men jag är en problemlösare med stort hjärta och ser lösningar i saker som folk har problem med.
Jag tänker att du är uppfinnare, du vet såhär, så som man tänkte när man var liten, att fan när jag blir stor vill jag bli uppfinnare, det var ju det man ville bli liksom.
Ja och jag var nog uppfinnare när jag var liten, för jag uppfann massa grejer och hittade lösningar på en massa prylar liksom.
Men det är ingenting som jag egentligen har tagit i marknad, utan jag är ju en born race säljare och entreprenör till fingerspetsarna, så att jag nu fick bli uppfinnare också, det var en sån här bucket list grej som känns jäkligt rolig och får bocka av och får kalla sig, folk frågar, vad jobbar du med?
Ja, man förklarar sig bolag i 45 minuter, det går inte heller, så jag brukar säga uppfinnare och det är lite roligt.
För det är ju, men det är ju nu det svåra kommer, vad uppfinnare lätt brukar säga, det svåra är att få ut produkten och förklara den för en marknad, det är lite utmaning.
Men jag kan berätta lite om mina uppfinningar, jag kom ju på den för fem år sedan kanske, jag var på väg hem från Skåne, jag tror det var med en lov som det var nu, det var sportlov någonting.
Jag var i Skåne och jag åkte hem till Västerås där jag bor, jag mötte 5 000 takboksar på vägen hem.
Det satt jag i tag i en sju timme åkande där vägen, så jag satt och klurade, va fan, vad gör de av de här förbannade plastlådorna?
De använder det en vecka per år och så ska de förvara de där fem kvadratmeterna i sina dygbara hem.
Jag lovar att folk svär och tycker att det är en otroligt jobbig och skitprodukt som man måste ändå ha.
Där kom det igen då, så att det egentligen är så att man kunde göra smartare.
Så hade jag en sån här reflex, så att man kan slå runt armen, så att man kan knäcka runt.
Så den hade jag runt armen och där började jag spåna.
Det blir en hård botten och sen blir det liksom en, när man inte använder kan man bara rulla ihop den och sen blir det en mellanrum i mitten där, där kan man ha en typ av box som man har sett.
Det blir hård och stabil och sen kan man göra något.
Så där började idén.
Så tog det väl kanske två år när jag fick Ashley-vagnen att åka och köpa och då köpte jag en plåt till botten, jag åkte och köpte en för Linköping och köpte en industrisinmaskin och sen började jag producera och det där tog ett år att ta fram en produkt men också sen sökte patent på.
Så där var det ju lärresan då och jag fick det här patentet.
Det tog två år så det är inte bara en människa.
Vi som är så gör jag sånt själva och ska lösa alla puckar och det var samma med twistbox.
Jag gjorde varenda liten pop-nit, varenda liten detalj, sydde själva första prototypen och sökte patentet.
Det vart ju en riktigt jäkla bra produkt utan att veta enkelt vad jag gjorde.
Så började det.
Men är det i all sin enkelhet så är det liksom en fällbar takbox?
Är det så man beskriver det eller hur?
För den är inte mjuk, den blir hård liksom.
Det är det här som är så otroligt svårt för det är såhär, det är en hård, det är en plastbox som finns idag, fast den är mjuk och kan rullas ihop till 30 cm.
För det är en klassisk plastbox som du vet vad det är, som du har haft hela dina år, som alla vet vad man kan relatera i.
Det är vad det är för den är stenhård.
Du kan sitta på den tom och du kan köra i 250 kmh med den, utan att den fladdrar och rör sig och så vidare.
Så det är vart en produkt som är som alla andra när den är på biltaket, men när du inte har den på biltaket så får den plats i din garabel eller under din säng.
Sen kom det så mycket mer med boxen.
Den är världens säkraste takbox.
Nu har jag fått lite bastning på det där för jag har inte fått att säga det, för jag har inte testat alla takboxer i världen.
Men, probably the safest box in the world.
By far kan jag säga att det finns ingen som slår sig på fingrarna där, för vi har en konstruktion som skiljer sig så mycket från en klassisk plastbox, som gjord av plast, vår är gjord av rostfritt stål.
Så det är liksom, det är...
Och det här får folk inte ihop i huvudet.
Jag tror faktiskt att det här funkar liksom.
Jag ska komma tillbaka till det så alla ni som sitter och tänker, fan ska du bara sidestäppa det här med säkerhetsgrejer innan, nej, ta det lugnt, ta det lugnt, vi hamnar där sen.
Men jag vill bara först på, är det liksom det som ditt patent är eller det som är själva uspen, det är väl det fällbara då?
Finns det inte andra fällbara?
Jag har ju sett mjuka saker som man har på taken liksom, och jag har ju sett de här hårda, klassiska.
Men är det det här fällbara eller vad du ska kalla det ihop, vikningsbara, rullbara, är det det som är liksom grejen?
Själva patentet är ett stabiliseringsfred som sitter i själva boxen, som gör att vi kan få den här rostfria stålbotten som det är.
Hela konstruktionen är gjorda av stål, alltså själva liksom skelettet i konstruktionen är gjorda av rostfritt stål.
Och på den sitter vår patentel som gör den stabil och hård, att vara säkraste boxen i världen på taket, och kan även göra den mjuk och fullstann, så att du kan rulla ihop den på 30 sekunder och ha den i din garderob eller under din säng.
På den sitter integrerat inbyggt i själva boxen är själva patentdelen.
Så du kan inte få patent på att rulla ihop en sak.
Det finns ju redan.
De själva patentdelen är ju där.
Och de här, som du ser, de här mjuka takboxerna, det finns ju tusen varianter av saker man sätter på bildtaken.
Men jag brukar relatera i så här att vill du sätta mjuk sak på taket, jag tar en svartrop säck, sätter den på taket och spänner fast med remma.
Det är det de säljer.
Och så finns det sådana i vattentäta plastmaterial, det finns ju tusen varianter.
Men det är en väska på taket som du spänner fast runt dörren eller in i fönstret.
Och ofta är det så att det går fast att lägga en dufferbag på taket.
DeVid Twistbox är en klassisk plastlåda, plastbox som finns idag, som vi har haft i 30 år.
De här riktigt mossiga gamla produkterna.
Det är en sån här på bildtaken, men den är modern och fräsch.
Den har ju lite snygga design och lite mer finessare än den klassiska takboxen.
Men det kan vi gå in på sen.
Men den är liksom, och det är det som är lite skillnad än så att, för det är liksom alltid, jag har sett att det finns någon liknande, men ja, det är ju den här väskan, den kan du ju inte ha skidor i.
Du kanske kan ha några påsar med kläder i i tid på sin höjd.
Så vill du frakta någonting i 250 km i timmen och åka till Alperna så...
Vill du köra autobahn helt enkelt.
Precis.
Men får man inte glömma en vanlig plastbox där får du bara köra 110 km i timmen.
Jag tror det är 110-120 km i timmen.
För annars kan du flyga dem av taket, för det är bara gjort av plast.
Det är 3 mm plast, så det håller inte om vinden tar dig en plastbox.
Det här vet ju inte mer än en man om därute, att de åker runt med någon livsfarlig sak på taket.
Men en frisk box är ju en helt annan konstruktion, så du kan ju gasa hur fort du vill på autobahn.
Det är det första tyskarna frågar, hur fort får jag köpa autobahn?
Det är bara att gasa sig här.
Har du varit ut och kört sådana tester på sådana lottbanor, typ i 280, har du kört?
Ja, vi har kört alltmunt.
Vi har tokbromsat i 100 kmh, vi har gjort alla de där grejerna.
Men vi ska inte fastna i konstruktionen, det är bara att jag tycker det är lite spännande.
Du säger att det är liksom som ett vred, är det ett vred då eller måste man bryda varje detalj i sig?
Hur krånglig är den här?
Om jag försöker hitta fel, jag vill bara förstå.
Den är otroligt användarvänlig.
Jag kan säga att alla klarar av den, om du är 6 år eller om du är 85 och heter Agda, så fixar du och sätter på den här på ditt bildtak.
En väldigt enkel konstruktion, det tar ungefär 15 sekunder att göra den hård och stabil, så du sen kan sätta den på ditt tak.
Så det tar inte mer tid, allt är integrerat.
Du vrider några avred och då klickar i en säkerhetsspärr så att det blir två längsgående kanaler på den här plåten som gör den tokstabil och hård.
Så hela den här skelettkonstruktionen som jag pratade om, du tänker som en släde, så det är hela botten som en plåt och så går det upp i fronten som en släde som också gör att ingenting kan flyga ut i fronten.
Och den där hela den stora plåten som är 2 meter lång, 80 centimeter bred, blir hård och stabil med de här stabiliseringsvreden som man vrider.
Och det är fem stabiliseringsvred som du vrider och klickar i 15 sekunders tid ungefär.
Så att det är så här, kan man, jag vet inte vad, jag ska jämföra dem.
Men det är en otrolig, alla klarar av att göra.
Det är inte så att man står och inte fattar hur man ska få den hård och stabil, eller mjuk och följsam.
Du har ju en viss energi som människa.
Jag, nu hör väl alla ni som lyssnar på det här, men jag har även träffat dig på något event här i Stockholm för några månader.
Vi bara sprang på varandra efter eventet liksom.
Men även då hade du samma energinivå skulle jag säga.
Det är inte, jag ser ju dig mer som en säljarpersonlighet eller liknande än en uppfinnare.
Känner du att, ja men du vet, du ska ju in i marknadsföring liksom.
Är det, känner du dig hemma nu när produkten är på plats och du får sätta igång och börja marknadsföra upp detta?
Ja, jag älskar ju marknadsföring, jag älskar sälja, jag älskar ut där och testa saker.
Men också så har ju det gjort att jag har, de styrkorna har ju tagit mig dit jag är idag med tanke på att 2% av alla idéer som kommer in till Potentivisteringsverket blir en färdig produkt.
2%, så tänk två grejer som åker i graven.
Det kan jag också säga att det är de här klassiska uppfinnarna.
De är jävligt bright och smarta och kan komma på en smart produkt men sedan tar de till marknad, det är ju det som är det svåra.
Karl som har jobbat på Patentivisteringsverket sa till mig vilket vi 2% av alla produkter blir en färdig produkt.
Börja producera, börja göra något, sitta inte och vänta på det här patenter.
Så jag började och gjorde en färdig produkt.
Så jag var klar kanske efter en vecka och skickade en bild till han och hans anfall.
Hur funkar det?
Hur är du klar?
Det här var ju min drivkraft.
Jag känner att få ta det här steget, och sen finns det ytterligare steg att ta den här produkten du har gjort och ge den till marknaden.
Det är också ett spärr som uppfinnare har, att man petar in ens lilla bebis, släppa ut den på marknaden och låta folk få syna in i sommarna.
Det är ju superläskigt, och det var läskigt för mig också, att jag släppte Generation 1, som nu är vi på Generation 3 idag.
Det var en hemmajord produkt som rullade på vägarna idag och funkar hur bra som helst.
Men att våga stäppa ut den och se vad som säger världen, vad säger kunderna när de åker med den här, det var superläskigt.
Men det är också en driftkraftig är att våga gå ut på den här plankan och ta det här steget.
Hur skedde det?
Du säger hemmajordprodukt, menar du att du satt hemma och byggde den där takboxen?
Hur var Version 1?
Version 1 gjorde jag i mitt garage, jag sydde den själv.
Jag åkte till Bauas och köpte en dammduk som du ska bygga en damm i din trädgård.
Det var en svartduk som är ålderbeständig, UV-resistent och så vidare.
Så jag köpte en sådan på Bauas på Rulle, tog hem, sydde den där i den här industrisynmaskinen, gjorde hela konstruktionen och det får också tänka att det här tog några år att hitta den här.
Hur ska jag få väggar och lock stabilt så att jag kan sitta på den när den är tom?
Hur löser jag det?
Så ska den ändå vara hoppdurbar och så vidare.
Jag hittade lösningar och material och göra alla de här sakerna, man måste ju vara lite knäpp för att klara av det där.
Så jag håller ju på därute i timmar i garage kan jag säga.
Jag gjorde de första, funkade, åkte runt med dem själv i ett år, åkte till Åresälen och hur bra som helst.
Så inser jag att jag inte kan sälja en egen sumnad grej.
Då gick jag till Polen och fick de jag själva sumnadsdelen, men patentdelen ville jag ha själv i garaget och inte ge bort det.
Så jag köpte själva sumnadsdelen så att den var snygg och riktigt gjord av en fabrik.
De skickade till Västerås, till mitt garage och där satt jag ihop själva generation 1, prototyperna som vi sålde som nummer ett.
Så jag popknittade fast den här plåten ihop med den här väskan som är upp till och började där och lanserade generation 1.
Det gick otroligt bra, sålde ju slut direkt.
Efterfrågan var ju egentligen för stor från dag ett.
Min vision var att tillverka en efterförsäljning.
Hur lanserade du, hur gick själva lanseringen till?
Jag gjorde en kickstarter-kampanj.
Det är ju ett crowdfunding-grej i USA som är rätt stor.
Så jag testade och slängde ut den där.
Det var ju också bara att göra.
För mig var det en marknadsundersökning.
Jag lägger upp den där på kickstarter och ser vad.
För den vet jag är världs sida, crowdfunding.
Och så är den så amerikansk, den här crowdfunding och kickstarter.
Så jag gjorde alla fel.
Alltså alla fel man kan göra.
Men det gick hur bra som helst.
Vi fick en fondad som vet att man får in pengar för det man vill ha.
Vi sålde slut på de här boxarna.
Det roliga var att på några veckor hade jag sålt till Malaysia, Dubai, Kanada, Frankrike, Tyskland, Slovenien.
Jag hade sålt spritt över i Hälteå och New York och så vidare.
Så vi sålde slut de här boxarna som jag hade gjort i mitt garage och så där.
Jag insåg att jag inte skulle vara intresserad av det här i Sverige och Norge och Finland.
Det är vi som har takboxar.
Men det hade jag helt fel.
Jag hade inte gjort min marknadsundersökning och förstod att världen behöver den här produkten.
Vi i Sverige kan ha den för vi bor stort.
Alla har en hytte i Norge och alla har en garage eller nånting.
Man kan ställa en takbox.
Men bor du i New York eller Manhattan så har du inte det.
Vi sålde flera till Manhattan och det var vår första kund också som köpte.
Det var lite roligt att det första boxen som levererades var till New York Manhattan.
Jag vet ju att du drar detta bolaget rätt mycket själv.
När jag lyssnar på detta så känns det som en licensieringsprodukt som man går ut till marknaden.
Man får en stor aktör och bara det här vill vi ha, vi lägger in detta i vårt sortiment och du får en kickback på 5% över resten av ditt liv och så är du klar.
Det är så jag ser det.
Varför har du inte gått den lägen?
Som jag säger, en envis entreprenör med galna tankar.
Jag är ju så här, jag ska göra twistbox ska bli Spotify, plastbox, casetbandet.
Jag ska förändra en värld som man sett likadan eller en bransch som man sett likadan utan senast i 30 åren.
Det har inte hänt någonting.
Det är det som händer att de blir smalare och smalare och smalare och plastigare och plastigare.
Jag vill göra någonting nytt, jag vill förändra något.
Sen om jag tjänar 100 miljoner eller 10 miljoner, pengar vill jag tjäna för det är ju klart man vill göra det.
Men inte det som är drivkraften.
Drivkraften är för mig att bygga ett varumärke och göra någonting som folk kommer ihåg och säger kommer ihåg.
När man hissa upp plastlådor i taket i garaget, varför gjorde man det för?
Varför lägger man inte dem under sängen eller i garderoben?
Det är där jag vill komma, det är det jag vill förändra.
Sedan går jag igång på att prata med marknaden, precis som du sa, jag vill göra saker, jag vill testa saker nu som jag aldrig har fått möjlighet att göra.
Jag har ju jobbat med alla stora kända varumärken i hela mitt liv, men att få bli och testa om jag kan driva det här till bitkänt varumärken, det är det som min drivkraft är.
Nu vet jag att jag har världens bästa produkten, den är helt outstanding och varit mycket bättre än jag trodde och alla teser som du säger, hur mycket man kan gräva och försöka hitta de klassiska plastboxen har ju ändå det här.
Den tesen finns inte, den klassiska takboxen har ingenting som inte twistboxen har.
Det kan vi gå in på sen i alla de här usparna.
Det har blivit bonus, det var ingenting jag tänkte på när jag satt och sydde den första twistboxen i min garage utan wow den är, den spar 25% luftmotstånd när du kör så den är mycket mer bensin-effektiv och energisnål.
Den är helt knäpptyst, den är jätteamendanvänlig, den får plats överallt.
Du kan köra hur fort du vill med den, den är säkrast i världen.
Så det finns inget som, så därför är jag helt uff, det är om fem år kommer det inte finnas en plastbox kvar.
Varför ska du ha en plastlåda?
Försök att du trycker, det är en lekskista på taket som du åker runt med och det är ju precis vad du gör.
En riktigt omodern gammal produkt som inte funkar.
Och vi har en lösning på en, en simpel lösning på en världsunik produkt som kommer att förändra det här.
Det är liksom, det är bara fakta.
Och vem blir först, vem gör det bäst?
För det kommer vara twistbox, vi är nummer ett och vi kommer att göra det bäst.
Det finns liksom inget annat.
Så det här, och jag säger så här, vi är i en värld där vi siktar på storstäderna.
Vi har halva världens befolkning bor i storstäder.
Vi är helt ensamma, det finns ingen konkurrens där.
Vi är den enda som kan sälja till den marknaden idag.
För vi har en produkt som de behöver, för de vill kampa, de vill ut och vandra, de vill åka skidor.
Men de har ingen möjlighet att göra idag.
För bor du i Manhattan, New York så har inte du ett förrådare i stället, det är en takbox.
Du kommer inte ens ner i garage med din takbox, för den är för stor på din bil.
Så här måste du liksom, på tv-box kan du bara fälla ner och känna dig platt.
Så den kommer ju förändra här och elbilarna blir mindre, bostäderna blir mindre, storstäderna växer och vi får ett jättesuga att gå ut i naturen.
Så att vi är helt rätt i tiden.
Det är liksom spot on är vi.
Det är ju lätt att känna att du är entusiastisk.
Och bodlig optimist.
Exakt, exakt.
Och jag menar inget illa men jag ska försöka trasha ner detta nu då, för det är ju så jag brukar jobba.
Jag tycker att alla alltid håller med för mycket.
Men nu får inte lyssnarna tro att jag är anti-freont, men jag tycker bara det är intressant att ifrågasätta.
Men fanns det på riktigt inga andra, vad ska vi kalla det, klickbara eller fällbara takboxar som blir hårda på marknaden när du började?
Och har det inte kommit konkurrenter under den här tiden?
Nej, jag vet ju att det finns en stor konkurrent som säljer plastboxar, som har gjort en djukt takbox.
Som egentligen är en skitprodukt.
De har även slutat med den för den funkar inte och den var inte bra.
Folk har ju försökt att gå in här, folk har ju sett men inte förstått lösningen.
Det roliga är att jag har varit ju faktiskt kontaktad av några ingenjörer som har jobbat åt ett stort företag och haft som vision att ta fram just det twistbox då för.
Det har varit målet för dem och det var alltså fem stycken som under flera år jobbade här.
Utan att lyckas.
De fick inte säkerhet i det, de fick det inte att funka.
Så man lade ner det projektet.
Så folk har försökt göra en twistbox i många många år utan att lyckas med det.
Det är som du sa lite, ja vafan det är väl rätt självklart, varför ska man, du behöver ha en stor väska på taket som funkar, men hur ska du göra det utan att behöva ha en likkista, en plastlåda?
Ja när man ser produkten eller liksom, man kan ju gå in och kika på din hemsida, den är rätt snygg liksom, den ser inte ut som en tygväska, utan det är liksom en slickprodukt liksom.
Men är det så jävla svårt liksom för folk att ta fram, vad var det som var, med all respekt för en bar du har tagit fram, men liksom det är ju en smidig lösning liksom.
Vad är det som är så krångligt här?
Det ska sägas att det här är så jävla roligt för alla säger, alla, då snackar jag hela världen, varför har ingen tänkt på det här för?
Det här måste ju finnas, det är det jag får, alla.
Varför har ingen tänkt på det här och det här måste finnas?
Ingen har tänkt på det och det finns inte.
För det är så otroligt, otroligt enkelt.
Det är inget komplext alls.
Det är en otroligt smart, enkel lösning.
Och då säger jag så här, det är lite svenskt.
Vi är ju väldigt kända för att göra enkla, smarta uppfinningar.
Det är Sverige kända för.
Jag hade faktiskt en amerikan som kom till mig på ispomessan, han har en svenskt fru, så stod han och snackade med mig, han sa för fan vad smart sa han.
Så sa han, jag ska visa dig en sak.
Då han har upp sin mobil, gick han in på anteckningar, så hade han skiftnyckeln, han hade dragkedjan, tändstickan, han hade ABBA, han hade Volvo, han hade alla de här.
Så sa han, kolla här nu, nu ska jag skriva dig Twistbox, för det här kommer att bli stort sånt.
Det här kommer att bli hur stort som är, för det är så jävla simpelt.
Och jag är så imponerad att det här landet med 10 miljoner människor kan göra så många uppfinningar, och de gör det så enkelt.
Ska vi göra i USA, så hade du varit så avancerad så hade ingen ens förstått det sånt, och det är lite amerikanskt.
När svenskarna gör det, vi tänker så simpelt och enkelt.
Twistbox är en otroligt enkel, smart uppfinning.
Och just därför tror jag så stenhårt på att det kommer att bli.
Det kommer att finnas i världens alla hörn inom några år, och det är helt oerhört tydligare än dem.
För att alla kan förstå den, alla kan relatera till den, så är det vår uppgift idag att berätta för folk att den är som en plastbox, fast mycket bättre.
Det är det folk inte tror idag, det är vårt.
Kan vi inte gå in i det här med säkerhet då, för att det är väl, jag bara gissar att om man ska köpa en takbox med då, så tänker man att det finns de där standardiserade hårda, och det är väl det som sätter stopp i huvudet då om man ska gå in på en twistbox då, eftersom det är en ny produkt, att det blir såhär, ja men är den trygg liksom.
För du säger ju här probably the best, eller probably the safest.
Vad är det som du bygger det på?
Finns det något branschorgan som tar fram det?
Hur sker liksom testningen och vad är det?
När du gör det claimet kan du bara, inte en halvtimme nu, jag förstår det, inte en halvtimme, men ge mig två minuter i alla fall.
Det här går jag igång på så jävla mycket, för folk som du säger, köper jag en plastbox, då har jag en säkerbox.
Fan de köper en jävla dödsfälla.
I dag med en klassisk takbox, om du åker och bromsar i 30 kmh, då flyger den där av taket.
Om du har 75 kilo i din plastbox, och så kommer du i 30 kmh och så tvärbromsar du, då håller du inte plasten, för det är 3-4 mm plast, det spricker, det kan ni inte hålla.
Så takboxen åker av och in i bilen framför dig, och du kanske blir våldad till annars död om du har jävligt otull.
Eller om du åker vid ett övergångsställe och du tvärnitar i 20 kmh, då åker den där av och ner på fotgängaren framför dig.
Det här förstår inte folk.
De gjorde en test på det här där boxarna flyg av, jag tror det var en stor skänt senare namnet, den åkte av i 12 kmh och kostade 18 000.
Så bromsade du med en takbox i 12 kmh och så flygde den av.
Då gick alla de här takboxbranschen ihop och så gjorde de såhär, vi måste fixa ett säkerhetsrumme, då kallar de det city brake test, så att du ska kunna åka vid tre lyser och bromsa utan att boxen åker av.
Då satt de, okej vi klarar city brake test så att du har den här stämpen på hälsidan.
Det betyder att du klarar 16-18 kmh vid en kraftig inbromsning.
Så boxen ska sitta kvar om du bromsar i 16-18 kmh, vilket är helt sjukt och de flesta klarar inte det.
Vi har gjort samma test med 16-18 kmh, fullastad.
Bromsar allt vad vi kan.
Vi har inte plast i båten, rossig plåt kan inte åka av.
Det som åker av är takräckligt men plåten åker inte av.
Plus att vi har en plåt i fronten så ingenting kan flyga ut i fronten.
Vi har en helt annan konstruktion, vi kan inte ens jämföras med den klassiska plastboxen i säkerhet.
Vi snackar helt olika divisioner, vi är säkra eller inte säkra.
Nu har jag bokat RISE på det statliga institutet som ska göra det här, riktiga tester, så att den tredje part har gjort allt det här.
Vi är en liga för sig.
Samma sak att med en plastbox får du bara köra 110 km per timme, för annars flyger den av, men vinden tar den.
Kommer det en vind, då flyger den.
Plasten håller inte.
Du ser att du åker med mobilskål på taket, hårdrar den lite.
Så twistbox, vi åker med en helt annan grej.
Det här blir lite ledsamt för att jag måste förklara för folk, och folk tror inte att det kan vara säkert.
Det är klart att vi har ett okänt varumärke, så det blir min mission här i livet, att jag ska ut och predika om det här.
Jag blir nya Jesus och berätta för folk att det finns en säkrare produkt som också är mycket smidigare och bättre och snyggare.
Så där har vi liksom, och det här är ju frågan jag får, håll den, funkar det säkert?
Jag tänkte att det är ju det man liksom, alltid när det kommer något nytt så är det ju det man tänker.
Men menar du att vanliga, lägger inte de bara plåt in i höllget?
Nej okej, man gör inte det.
Är det för dyrt eller?
Nej, de gjuter en plastlåda.
Vissa har lagt en järnkonstruktion eller plot, eller i där man sätter själva fästet på takräcket.
Då lägger man en järnshak som man har då, så att det blir en järnlist precis där du spänner fast.
Det är fortfarande plast runt den.
Så det hjälper liksom inte så mycket.
Hela våra botten är järn.
De har ju bara kanske två decimeter järn, om de vill förstärka.
Det är bara vissa som har det, de som är lite dyrare.
De här billiga tockboxarna har absolut inte det.
Det är en väldigt skranglig plastkonstruktion, som popnitar med plastnitar och så vidare.
Alla detaljer är twistboxen gjord i rostrigt stål.
Det finns ingen detalj som kan rosta.
Det finns ingen, allt är gjort i högkvaliteterad material för att vara det säkraste.
Vi ska vara säkraste i världen och då ska vi stå för det.
Så att det blir vår mission här att framhänta att detaljer skulle vara nittigryttiga så att ingen, vi ska vara bästa produkten by far.
Och det är vi idag kan jag säga.
Hur mycket skit har du fått från de andra i Ibna?
Du är relativt frispråkig.
Har du fått?
Ja, jag kan säga så.
Jag har fått ett mail från en stor konkurrens-vd som skrev hur kan du säga att du är världens säkraste talkbox?
Och du testar alla i världen.
Det var då jag ändrade på hemsidan från safest roofbox in the world till probably the safest roofbox in the world.
Så får Karlsberg här av sig istället.
Du får göra någon collab med dem.
Ja, jag känner mitt så att...
Jag har gjort en produkt mycket bättre än alla de andra gjort och så är det.
De kan inte säga så mycket, de vet också.
De förstår att...
Jag är också respektfria för på vår hemsida om du går in och ska köpa en twistbox och sen har du en stor konkurrent som du vet att det funkar till 30 obv.
Ja, fan ska jag välja liksom.
Jag såg ju den spärren, så jag skrev det på vår hemsida och gjorde faktiskt att nyligen såhär, okej, not ready to buy, rent it.
Sen 200 spänn i veckan, hyr den för 200 spänn.
Den kostar ju 100 kronor att frakta via hela Sverige.
Vi frakta från vårt lager i Kungsör till Tyskland för 118 spänn.
Så att vi frakta en liten låda som du hämtar ut på din utlämningsställe.
Du hämtar ut den på ICA eller Konsum eller Presbyrån.
Den här kommer som ett par ins eller ett par skor.
Det är ju inte, det ska ni se jävla häftigt.
Det är 520 pakliters takboks som kommer i en liten låda som du går och hämtar på ICA.
Den väger bara 16 kilo och så är den 30-40% lättare eller 50% lättare än en klassisk takboks.
Så den kan skickas som ett par dojor.
Så att du köper som ett par skor på Nelle, samma sak och du hämtar ut det på samma sätt.
Så vi revolutionerar ju den aspekten.
Det är därför vi är.
Vi är en väpprodukt.
Vi ska bli ett techbolag på esport.com.
Vi ska skicka takboks över hela världen, åt enkelt smidigt.
Jag vet ju att du har signat upp ett gäng återkäljare och som du säger är det också en e-addelsprodukt på många sätt.
Och den är ju relativt...
Jag köper ju hela säljargumentet.
Varför, med all respekt för att ni typ fyrdubblade förra året, men det är ju fortfarande några miljoner i omsättning.
Varför är ni inte större ännu snabbare?
Vad är stoppet i...?
Med tanke såhär, vi lanserade produkten under 2024 och egentligen första halvåret hade vi...
Aha, ni lanserade i 2024?
Okej, jag ser bara såhär omsättning 2023.
Ja, 2023, då i november så startade Kickstarter liksom.
Då hade jag liksom, det gjorde jag i garaget hemma.
2024 så liksom hela...
Så nu har vi en produktion på 100 om dagen.
Vi producerar i Kina i egenägda fabriker faktiskt.
Så en av mina deltagare har gått in, men det kanske vi kommer ta senare.
Så vi har en jätteproduktion idag och tänkte för ett år sedan, då satt jag i garaget i princip.
Så att det har gått väldigt fort och vi har faktiskt 49 återförsäljare i 15 länder.
Och det här gjorde jag själv under 2024.
Så produkten har sålt sig själv.
Och till det här kommer att vi inte har marknadsfört oss.
Jag lade ut 17 000 marknadsföring 2024.
Så jag har ju med AI och hjälp av mig själv lyckats sälja till hela världen.
Och då menar jag hela världen.
Jag har tre återförkällare i Taiwan, bara det liksom.
Så det är svärt.
Och det har jag lyckats med själv på ett halvår i princip.
För också första året så byggde vi upp hela produktionen, eller första halvåret, 2024.
Så byggde vi ner produktionen i Kina.
Vi fixade kartonger, vi gjorde leverans, strukturer, vi gjorde liksom hela den saken.
Och teamet bakom är ju liksom jag då.
Så vi har byggt någonting unikt på väldigt kort tid och fått respons från alla världens hörn.
Och återförsäljare runt om i världen.
Och jag fokuserar på återförsäljare och inte på twisterbox.com för jag inser själv att sälja en produkt på en webbsida utan reklam det är ju liksom att skyta sig själv i foten.
Det går ju inte.
Så att min vision har varit att få återförsäljare presentera produkten och all respekt till en dyr produkt.
Den kostar 10.000, 9.000, 9.000, 9.000, 5.000 till slutkund.
Och ska också säljas och förklaras utan en återförsäljare.
Såklart de har respekt för det.
Då har vi sålt till självklart klassiska takboksföretag, men de har inte varit de som har varit mest intresserade.
Utan de som varit mest intresserade är campingsbutiker, sportkedjor.
Där har vi fått jätte respons.
För de säljer alla produkter som folk behöver ha för att frakta.
Det enda de inte säljer är ju takboksen.
Nu kan de göra det på ett smidigt sätt och skicka sina kunder på webben eller i butik.
Det funkar ju överallt, du kan ju ha den på ICA.
Du kan ju köpa en box på ICA utan att det skulle störa.
Nu ska vi inte rigga på ICA, det är inte där vi ska vara.
Det finns säkert folk som lyssnar som tänker att det är en jävla snabb tillväxt.
Det är ett väldigt stort ordervärde och som du säger att det är en global produkt i sig.
Därför är jag lite intresserad på var själva Stockholms finns.
Jag vet också om att ni har egen produktion så jag vet att ni kan lämna upp det där.
Det är lite intressant.
Vad finns flaskhalsan någonstans i det här?
Flaskhalsan idag är egentligen att jag är ensam i bolaget.
Jag är den enda säljaren, jag är där.
Vi har byggt en struktur med AI så att vi ska kunna sälja till hela världen och bemöta hela världens frågor och efterfrågan.
Idag signar vi upp distributör, eller vad säger jag, återförsäljare med AI, vi skickar ut intressen mellan.
Just idag skickar vi ut ungefär 900 mails per dygn till världens alla.
Vi har en AI som skrapar marknaden efter web-adresser.
Allt som har sportbutik, allt som har camping i sig, allt som har surfbutik i sig, allt som har det skrapar vi och sen hittar vi dem.
Det är mycket infomejl och mycket sånt.
Där skickar vår AI ut ett brev som förklarar twistbox.
Känner ni, har ni sett att den här bedöms marknaden vid nya och sådär, är du intresserad av att bli återförsäljare?
Vi skickar direkt till alla sportbutik, camping, fiske, you name it, dygnet runt.
De här intressen mellan som vi får, när de svarar så skickar vår AI ett tack-mejl och förklarar mer.
Om de vill ha mer så skickar vi olika varianter på hur de ska svara.
Samt om de vill bli distributörer eller återförsäljare så skickar vi även ett onboarding-formulär.
Så att de lätt kan fylla i första tre frågorna, webbutik, mail och adress var de ligger.
Så får jag en cling att vi har fått en ny återförsäljare i California som en surfbutik.
Då kan jag gå och titta på den på webbsidan och se om den är bra.
Är den bra då drar jag den i mitt CRM som vi har gjort själva till Send Contract och Approved Customer.
Då skickas ett ombordningssystem nummer två där då återförsäljaren lätt kan skriva in sina uppgifter, leveransadresser, fakturadresser.
När de är klara med det så får de en inlag till deras OF-portal.
På OF-portalen kan de beställa butiksledning, de kan beställa takboxar, de kan beställa pall styckvis.
De kan även använda vår AI-motor för att generera marknadsföring till deras webbutik eller deras butik.
Så de skriver in, skriv familj sommar.
Då kommer det en färdig text från AI, besök vår fabrik, köp twistboxen på den här.
Och så genereras det en bild till det där, som de bara kan dra till likt in till Facebook eller Instagram.
Det här har vi byggt för att underlätta, för att vi ska ge åtförsäljaren möjlighet att marknadsföra twistbox.
För att vi ska spara pengar och slippa ta den, eller vi har inte den möjligheten, vi är nystartade.
Så vill vi få det här community med åtförsäljare att hjälpa oss som marknadsförare för ett twistbox.
Det här gör vi idag i hela världen och det funkar väldigt bra.
Problemet är att jag har inte tid med den personliga kontakten.
Jag har inte tid att ringa upp åtförsäljaren och prata med dem och fråga hur det går.
Har du sålt dem?
Varför har du inte sålt?
Förstår du hur du får ut den här AI-annonsen?
Och så vidare.
Så hela den här uppbyggnaden kommer jag på och har inte blivit i twistbox.
För mitt vision är att jag ska omsätta 100 miljoner utan anställda, vilket kommer vara jättesvårt, men det är mitt vision och det ska jag testa att göra.
Det nya framtida såtens företagande.
Där har en AI som svarar på alla chatbottnar, det har väl alla idag, men vi har 62 språk förra veckan som vår AI har frågat på.
Finns det en i svart?
Har ni en på lager?
Fraktar ni till Grekland?
Kan man köpa den i Indien?
Alla de här språken svarar på det, det är självklart.
Ska någon in reklamationer?
Har vi inte haft någon reklamation?
Peppan tar i trä så vi är riktigt nöjda där.
Då frågar AIen efter bilder.
Bilderna skickas till mig.
Allt det här är uppbyggt för att jag ska kunna hantera och signa upp i princip tusen återkäljare om dagen och kunna göra det själv.
Men vi är lite för tidigare där tror jag.
För att jag får jättemånga av de här skrapningar som man mailar och skickar ut.
Ja, vi är en fucking cool produkt, vi vill vara med.
Vi är surfbutiken som jag fick nu.
Det är så coolt att man kan ha surfbrädda uppe på twistboxen.
Den är mjuk och följsam så att du kan ha en surfbrädda upp och ner på den.
Sen kan du spänna fast den med remmar upp till för vi har två fästanordning uppe på.
Så man kan lätt fästa saker uppe på en supp eller en surfbrädda.
Så det ser skitcoolt ut när man kör.
Och de blir såhär, det här måste vi ha.
Då svarar abonnerna, beställ kontrakt dit, och de blir såhär, vi vill ta hem två, twistboxet bara.
Då har jag tappat den, de blir såhär, kontrakt, vi vill ju testa bara.
De kan köpa hem en eller två, de behöver inte göra något.
Men om jag ringer och säger till dem, ta hem två, jag skickar det här.
Då köper jag dem.
Så vi är för tidiga, vi är för snabba.
Vi har gått lite för snabbt fram och gjort det lite för automatiserat för en ny produkt.
Så vi tappar den personliga touchen.
Så just där sitter vi där att vi får otroligt många kunder i världen som vill köpa, men vi tappar dem lite inom onboardingprocessen.
För jag är inte med, för jag är själv.
Ombordingprocessen är supersmart och bra, men den är för aggressiv i sin utordning.
Här får du kontrakt, lägg order där och så vidare.
Så vi håller på att kolla, gör om det.
Vi ska ha mycket mjukare och mer härkontakt av Micke om du vill prata med en människa.
Men du har fortfarande tanken att du ska vara själv upp till hundra.
Finns det något självvända mål i det?
Förutom att det är en fix idé.
Ja det är en fix idé.
Om du skulle dra detta riktigt stort och globalt, så kommer du inte att tänka tillbaka och tänka va kul att jag drog upp på en person.
Men hade du inte bara tänkt att jag inte gjorde det här fyra år snabbare?
Jag kan ju säga att jag älskar ju socialt, jag älskar ju en kollega att hålla armkrok med.
Så jag kan ju hålla med det där.
Okej, om jag ville vara själv, men du är ju uppenbart trevlig.
Ja det är en fix idé, jag vill säga, då går det att göra.
Vad fan, AI säger alla, då går det ju liksom.
Det är det som har byggt, då ska jag bygga allt med AI.
Jag har ett vitt blad nu, jag har ett twistbox 1 då gammalt.
Jag har ett vitt papper, vad fan jag kan göra precis vad jag vill.
Då vill jag testa den här tesen.
Helt galet kanske, helt fel och kommer säkert inte funka.
Men jag ska prova och se hur långt jag kan dra det.
Just nu så har vi lite utmaningar med att vi blir lite opersonliga kanske, men hade produkten varit välkänd hade det funkat bra som helst.
Så det där är lite såhär, vad måste vi göra nu?
Vad lär vi oss av det här?
Och jag är såhär, jag går ut och testar, kör och sen tusen fel på vägen, men jag måste igen.
Och det är liksom, så länge magen känns, säger okej, då kör jag liksom.
Och det har jag sagt, lovat mig själv inför den här partnerskapet med Twistbox och det här bolaget att lyssna på magen.
Allt ska gå, det ska kännas gött och det ska vara roligt.
Sen har man tillräckligt magont ändå när man är entreprenör och ni startar ett bolag.
Men fan, gör vad magsenslan säger och lita på det.
Så det är det jag försöker gå på nu och testa.
Marknadsföringar, jag försöker provocera och hitta vägar och liksom göra roliga saker.
Folk bara, jag kan ju inte skriva, du kan inte lägga ut det där.
Fan det blir ju helt galet.
Ja varför då liksom?
Man ska ju testa liksom.
Helt plötsligt så smäller det och då blir det viralt och sen tycker folk att det är världens coolaste grej.
Så blir det inte det men ja, jag lovade mig själv.
Vad är din bakgrund?
Har du någon entreprenörsbakgrund sedan tidigare?
Har du drivit något åt det här hållet?
Jag har drivit massa bolag i mina dar, men det är inom klädbranschen.
Jag är liksom, det här som min tjej går för absolut att inte säga, jag brukar säga att jag är en gammal trashandlare.
Hon bara det är så negativt men...
Jag säger att jag är skrottsamlare så jag hoppar.
Ja det är lite samma.
Men du får inte säga det på podden för det låter så negativt.
Så jag är gammal, jag har sålt denim i jeans hela mitt liv.
Levi's Wrangler och modekläder liksom.
Så jag har haft massa jeasybutiker, de som gamla nog kommer ihåg det.
Jeans and clothes, back in the days.
Och någonting som heter Root Buffler.
Så jag har haft massa butiker runtom i mellan Sverige här.
Där har jag drivit de här.
Cläbranschen är så jäkla rolig, men itgepöl går inte att tjäna pengar.
De är omoderna efter tre veckor, får du redan för 90 procent.
Det är en rolig bransch men svår att tjäna pengar i.
Så jag kommer från entreprenörskapet, så att starta egna bolag, testa egna varumärken och så där.
Men det här är helt nytt.
Jag har ingenting med takbox eller kunde, nu är jag expert men jag gillar att bygga varumärk och göra det.
Så om man säljer en takbox eller ett par jeans, det är egentligen skitsamma.
Det ska ut och presenteras på samma sätt, det ska skickas till kund på samma sätt, och det ska säljas in och marknadsföras på samma sätt.
Jag vill ju marknadsföra Twistbox som den nya, fräsch, trendiga, moderna, kvinnliga.
Alltså där vi jobbar med design, det ska vara fashion i produkten, den är mjuk, följsad, det är inte den plastiga, hårda.
Det ska vara schysst ihop med...
Det skulle lätt kunna gjort när Barbiefilmen släpptes, gjort den rosa takboxen för Barbie på, och riktade oss till en helt annan målgrupp mot den traditionella gubbbranschen som den kommer ifrån.
Så jag vill liksom twista det här och göra det här modernt och lätt.
Kan du ge några exempel på hur du har gjort?
Finns det något sånt?
Jag har så jävla roliga, jag startade Twistbox för ett och ett halvt år, sen gjorde jag den här filen för hur varumärket ska se ut.
Jag gjorde min mood-board, då tog jag en massa neon, snabba grejer och flashit.
Sen hittade jag en bild på en gammal nunna, den här 70-basen, hon sitter i sitt kloster och sen sitter hon och plackar fingret.
Hon gör alltså fuck you-fingret i den här nunnan.
Sen står det, how to say fuck you in a nice way.
Jag bara, där har vi det.
Där har vi det, how to say fuck you.
Vi måste vara ödmjuka inför marknaden, för vi är lite stora, vi är små.
Vi ska säga fuck you till en bransch som inte har sett någon utveckling i 30 år.
Vi ska göra det modernt, fräscht, ungdomligt.
Alla kan hantera en takbok, det ska finnas alla hem.
Vi träffade reklambyrån som sa, kolla.
De sa, nej, det kan du inte göra.
Du kommer ju bränna dig helt.
Jag bara, jag vill göra det.
Jag har pratat med tre reklambyrån och alla har sagt nej.
Det är fortfarande, det sa jag på min bordbord.
Jag ska använda det en dag.
Jag har provisat det några gånger, men liksom det är inte där Twistbox ska vara.
Vi ska säga, fuck you men på ett ödmjukt sätt, för vi är en små, vi är liten spelare, vi är inte stora, men vi ska ändå våga stäcka ut hakan och göra det som de andra inte gör.
För om vi tänker bara nu, om jag tar Volvo, jag tar Thule, jag tar Kia, jag tar alla de här varumärkena, och sen bara tar du bort loggan och byter plats på dem.
Du skulle inte veta vilken reklam det är.
Du vet inte om det är Volvo, om det är Thule, eller om det är Kia, eller om det är...
Listan kan göra en så lång.
Och det är så här, där ska inte vi gå.
Vi ska synnas tydligt vad Twistbox står för, och vi ska inte vara den där, utan vi ska hitta den andra vägen.
Och vad det är, det vet jag inte.
Men det är det jag ska försöka lista ut, och där kommer vi att se mycket roliga och konstiga saker under åren här, jag lovar att jag själv också vågar hitta den där vägen där ingen annan går.
Och den är jätteläskig, för ingen annan har gjort det.
Och alla säger, men du måste gå den här vägen, för här är det så här man gör.
Okej, men då går jag höger istället, för där har ingen gått.
Jag bara tänker att det känns som, nu låter det som att jag förespråkar din takbox här, men jag har inte testat den här till folk, men om det du säger är rimligt här, så det känns som att det är ganska lätt att göra jämförelsefilmer, till exempel om vi säger breaktest så hade det varit ganska nice att ha en GoPro-kamera inne i takboxet samtidigt som man kör i 100 km i timmen.
Så har man verktygslåda där inne och ser hur den flyger mot fronten, men det händer ingenting.
Sånt borde man göra upp eller så här, här har vi fyra personer som ska sätta upp en takbox på ett tak jämfört med en person som gör det och så har man en tävling på stan med vilka är snabbast.
Det finns ju ganska enkel sådant.
Jag hittar liksom, skulle jag köpa din produkt här så hade jag varit mest orolig för att det här tar tid och är krångligt att sätta upp.
För att det låter, jag gillar att den är mjuk och ihopföljbar, men i mitt huvud, jag har inte ihop att det ska gå så snabbt.
Du säger 15-30 sekunder.
Jag hade velat se liksom hur snabbt och enkelt.
Vi har ju en film egentligen, det är en tjej som sätter på den på taket som vi har på lite sådär på olika ställen, på vår hemsida och det.
Hon gör det på, den filmen är på ämnen ut och då filmar vi hur hon gör det där.
Exakt.
Hon gör det helt själv den här tjejen.
Hon sätter på, man visar processen precis hur det funkar med den här vreden och allting.
Det här som du säger nu, och det är liksom, det är no-braining, klart vi ska göra det, men vi har inte haft tiden, vi har inte haft möjlighet.
Jag själv har gjort liksom en reklamkampanj jag inte hunnit med.
Vi har inte ens gjort en vinterreklam än.
Jag hittade filmen nu men jag vågade inte trycka på den för att låta det i bakgrunden.
Men okej, då är jag med.
Ja, och det visar ju liksom det här, men det som du alltid säger, det är no-braining, klart vi ska göra det, men vi har inte funnits i tiden.
Jag har liksom missat fönster med vinterreklam igen, för jag har inte hunnit gjort det.
Och vi är såhär, fan, har vi fortfarande ingen vinterbild på takboksarna, att man kan ha skidor in liksom.
Och det är såhär, fan.
Nej, vi har mycket kvar att göra.
Ska du fortfarande vara ensam i bolag?
Nej, jag får kanske börja tänka om här.
Nej, men också såhär, som jag har byggt det här bolaget så har jag byggt det som ett pussel.
Jag vet ju vad min namn är, Mikael Lellup, vad är dina styrkor?
Jag är en säljare som gör, jag kan sälja det mesta.
Och det älskar jag.
Jag ska ut till hela världen och jag ska presentera Twistbox.
Och sen så finns det lite mer grejer, man ska ha en produktionsbit också som är hjälptavancerad.
Och det är inte minst, jag tycker inte om produktion.
Nu har jag byggt den här takboksen men jag vill inte hålla på med det, jag vill inte sköta produktionen.
Då har jag tagit in en delägare som heter Stefan Körling, som har fått en del av bolaget, då sköter han all produktion.
Han äger två fabriker i Kina som är 100% svenskt ägda fabriker.
Så han äger dem och sköter all produktion där.
Vilket är helt magiskt.
Vi har världens bästa produktion och det är i twistboksen svår produkt att göra.
Så det kräver sin fabrik, giatomatiserad, summa, det är liksom allt.
Du kan inte sitta och hansyn för det är så otroligt amasserad produkt.
Det är hårt och mjukt som ska ihop och bli liksom en följsam komponent.
Och hela boxen är en komponent, inga lösa delar så allt är integrerat.
Så att få ihop allt i det här är en riktigt amasserad produkt.
Så det är inte lätt att bara kopiera en twistbox, det kan jag lova det.
Och sen har vi andra stycken som heter logistik, hela supply chain som är, jag får inte ens tänka på det.
Vi ska ha container från Shanghai till USA, vi ska ha container därifrån dit, vi ska ha container till Frankrike, vi ska skicka till slutkund dit, vi ska tillbaka dit och flyga dit.
Och så hela där har jag ett bolag som heter Packing AB som också delar i Twistbox.
De sköter hela supply chain, hela automatiseringen i flödena av produkter över hela världen hit och dit.
För det är det vi kommer jobba med, vi kommer jobba med transporter över hela världen.
Och sen har vi sista delen som är AI också, som vi då har tagit in en kille som sköter all den här AI in, som är en AI expert som gör alla de här lösningarna så att vi kan bli framtidens bolag.
Vi ska ju bli techbolag, det är det vi ska bli.
Vi ska bli techbolag där vi har massa olika affärsmodeller.
Men i slutändan så kommer vi vara ett techbolag med massa olika saker som vi bygger på nu med uthyrningsmodeller och vi har massor av communities i vår plattform.
Och sen har vi då sista biten som är marknad, den pussigbiten håller jag på med nu, att försöka få marknad.
Hur kan vi bli bäst i världen på twistbox.com?
Hur kan alla kunder i världen veta att vilja köpa en twistbox i morgon?
Det är en jätteapparat att få ut twistbox.com i hela världen.
Det är nästa pusselbit som jag håller på att sätta på plats nu.
När jag väl har fått den på plats, då är mitt pussel klart.
Då har jag en plattform och en gedigen grund där vi kan bygga ett miljardbolag på.
Med Turflux, Mävind och allt vad som krävs med det.
Men vi har gjort gro jobbet, vi har gjort strukturen.
Jag tycker om den tanken du har tagit in delägare i dom, vad ska man säga?
Fråkiga segmenten.
Ja, exakt, eller dom som man behöver hjälp.
Eller dom som är i grunden, exakt.
Men är du då öppen för att ta in en marknadsföringsbyrå, eller är det någonting som, är det en tanke eller är det fortfarande en detaljtjänst?
Byrå, jag har fått väldigt mycket förfrågningar från reklambyråer och sådär som vill gå in och betala med sina marknadsföringspengar.
Men den potten tar ju slut en vacker dag, och det är lite allergiskt mot.
Vad händer den dagen potten är slut och ska man sitta och knä på dem?
Så att nej, utan jag ser mer på att få in det guru-nerden, den vem är bäst i världen på att göra det här.
Så det är så jag, okej, vem är bäst i världen på att göra produktionen?
Nej, det är Stefan Körling, för han har två fabriker och levererat hela världen.
Vilka är bäst på supply chain?
Jo, det är PackingObi, för de har ju sina system, de gör det här och så vidare och så vidare.
Så är det som jag tänker upp där, för jag vet ju mina begränsningar och mina styrkor och vad som kompletterar mig bäst.
Det är med superhjältar som är bäst i sin genre.
Det är så jag har byggt strukturen och gett bort mina ägarandelar i Twistbox för att få in det.
För jag vet att det är ett enda sätt att få nå en världsmarknad.
Och så här går det ihop då, vi har 250 anställda i fabriken och där sitter vi ingenjörer och väldigt i klambyråer som jag självklart Twistbox använder.
Så jag är ju inte själv, men jag är inga anställda i bolaget.
Så har jag packings som har massa anställda.
Så jag har ju motorer runt mig som hjälper mig i olika skeden.
Jag hjälper Twistbox just då.
Så det finns ju en styrka där bakom också.
Hur ser det 2025 ut?
Nu har det ju gått några månader bara men hur rullar det på?
Är ni liksom ett lönsamt bolag eller hur växer det?
Ja, vi har ju inte varit lönsamma hittills.
I 2023 hade vi ingen försäljning, det var mer utveckling som vi hade bara några.
2024 börjar vi det sista halvåret och får igång lite försäljning, produktionen var klar i Kina och så där.
Så vi var inte lönsamma, självklart, det är som min startup.
Men i år går det bra, vi har börjat riktigt bra, i januari, februari så har vi nästan slagit fjolåret redan i omsättning.
Men sen har vi också fortfarande inte noll kronomarknadsföring än idag, så vi har fortfarande inte tryckt på den knappen.
Där har väl jag tänkt att ta in lite pengar nu, kanske ta in en investerare som kan hjälpa oss med den här marknadsföringen.
Så det är väl ett steg nu som jag inte har tänkt före, med tanke på Draknäste som jag var med i där, valde jag att inte, så att säga.
Jag gick in med visionen att inte ta in, jag skulle inte få med mig att investera i nånting ifrån, om man ser så, jag var där för en helt annan syfte och det var det klan för Twistboxes, vilket de sa otaliga gånger, men du bara, härför töver vi den jävelen, men det är smart.
Det är smart så.
Jag var där inne en timme och 45 minuter i draknästet och vi förhandlade, det var svettigt.
Men en jäkligt rolig upplevelse.
Var du sugen eller?
Ja, jag erbjudde 4% av den som kommer ihåg, som såg avsnittet och de satt fyra drakar med på fem.
Då sa jag att vi skulle gå ihop och köra med fem.
Då sa jag att jag stannar på fyra.
De sa att jag måste kunna förhandla om en procent annars.
Då sa jag nej och då sa de att det inte skulle bli en del.
Jag sa att jag tackade för kaffet.
Det var en timme och 45 minuter, men det var ändå 14 minuter TV-tid, primetime i draknästet, så jag är supernervös.
Jätterolig TV, alla drakar var positiva, jag hade svar på tal på alla frågor, vilket jag var supernervös på, och det var ett jättebra TV, och det var syftet för twistbox-del i det här.
Men nu känner vi att vi kanske är redo att ta in pengarna, och vi behöver lite pengar.
Det blir draknästet USA eller draknästet Canada.
Jag har faktiskt funderat på att kolla om man kan hitta vägen in där, jag har hört att det är riktigt svårt, men det är värt att försöka, det kan vara en riktigt rolig grej att göra.
Det är ganska nice att kunna säga att man fick erbjudandet i Sverige, även om de skiter i det, men där erbjöd de på den här värderingen, och jag tackar er nej därför jag vill gå internationellt.
Man kan säga det på något sätt.
Man kan vara lite coolare, så att how to say fuck you in a nice way.
Exakt så.
Okej, vad tar du van att vända dig?
Om du ändå börjar tänka lite grann på att ta in investerare, eller skala upp via den pengadelen, eller hur går tankarna där?
Vad är det du letar efter?
Jag känner, min vision med allt det är att bygga varumärke.
Som säger Stak, jag letar efter investerare som vill gå in och hjälpa till att bygga varumärke.
Och pengar vi behöver är egentligen, vi vill lägga det i marknadsföringsspotten och testa.
Vad kan Twizypox göra med lite kickskassa i marknadsföringspengar när vi inte har lagt ner en krona och vi finns i hela världen redan idag.
Så det ska vara väldigt intressant och det triggar mig lite såhär, fan vad kan vi göra?
Och sen har jag stort respekt för det svarta hålet därute.
Jag menar, ni vet själva att man slänger pengar i meter, det är liksom stort svart hål.
Du kan lösa med hur mycket du vill där.
Om du inte har världens bästa guru som vet precis vad du ska skruva, vad du ska göra i varje detalj.
Vi snackar kirurgisk precision, det är det jag vill ha.
Det är därför jag letar efter den här nörden som kan ta den här marknadsdelen.
Det pusslet är gjort då vi redan tar in pengar och då är vi redo att presentera Twistbox för världen på marknadsförings sätt.
Det är nu är vet jag inte.
Hur kommer det sig att ni inte har testat lite själv?
Jag tänker att rent procentuellt, om ni ändå har möjligheten att ha en återförsäljningsstruktur, så finns det ändå en, du behöver inte gå in på exakta procentandelar i marginal och sådär, men då har ni ju uppenbarligen en marginal för det och ni skickar via ombud, som du sa, det är annars en stor och hygglig.
Så det finns ju ändå en procentsats där som gör det möjligt att marknadsföra.
Var fan ni inte bara känt lite?
Ja men testat några hundra bara för att se vad som händer.
För att vi kan inte det, vi vet inte hur vi gör.
Jag har ingen aning.
Jag kan ringa 200 byråer i Stockholm och alla säger att de är världsbäst på det här.
Jag tror inte att de är världsbäst på det här.
Jag vill veta vem är världsbäst på det här.
Så nu har jag tagit reda på vem som är världsbäst på det här.
Och hans, den personen som ska med i mitt bolag som sista pusselbiten.
Sen kan vi börja med det här.
Så det är med all respekt och sen har vi liksom inte haft tid.
Så vi har inte haft kunskap på tid.
Som jag sa, det var en 17 000 marknadsföring förra året.
Vi köpte en Google-annons själva för att testa lite hur det funkade.
Jag älskar, jag älskar.
Vi köpte en Google-annons.
Ja det gick åt helvete, så det är väl så att vi ska inte hålla på med det där.
Jag gissar att du inte berättar vem den här är, men när i tiden kommer den här personen in då?
Nej, vi är inte klara än, utan det är liksom en resa.
Men jag är ju inte där och letar.
Men jag hoppas att vi kan nå i morgon.
Är du fortfarande öppen att få folk att skriva till dig på LinkedIn nu?
Ja, absolut.
Jag pratar och ingenting är klart för det fatlady-thing som orkar säga.
Men jag har mina visioner och mina tankar om jag vill och vad jag vill göra.
Jag är tydlig där, men sen är vi också öppen för investerare med.
Jag pratar med alla, men det ska vara rätt investera med rätt mindset, bygga varumärke, ha haft kanske gjort det tidigare och så vidare.
Eller sålt i olika länder och hållit på hela problematiken kring valutor och omsatser och tullar och vem vet jag.
Ja, bara valutorna är stora klem i huvudet nu.
Jag säljer ju liksom i alla valutor och det är ovet.
Men nu har det varit positivt de senaste veckorna här.
Trendat lite positivt för oss.
Men vi jobbar ju många, vi jobbar ju både i US och euro och det är sek och det är jämn nu då från Japan.
Så det är många grejer man ska...
Och jag är såhär, man har respekt.
Man har ju sina skills och jag har mina skills såhär att jag kan sälja till marknaden och prata med de flesta runt om i världen.
Det är jag bra på.
Sen respekt för det andra, jag skulle inte hålla på med det för det är inte det jag och mina surkor är.
För det gäller att ta in rätt människor som är duktiga på det.
Mikael, vilken fantastisk resa du har gjort.
Fan vad spännande.
Det ska bli skitkul och...
Jag har ju dig på LinkedIn.
Jag kommer ju följa den här på LinkedIn-resan.
Så att man får följa dig.
Så det är ju roligt med någon som faktiskt har uppfunnit en produkt på egen hand.
Men det är ju inte ofta hundstiden.
Och en ting man kan ta på.
Du kan ta på den här.
Det är ingen deep tech-grej som kanske blir modern de 15 åren.
Nej men all respekt är ju liksom...
Man kan klämma på det, man kan känna på det.
Det är lite ovanligt att det finns sådana produkter fortfarande i världen som folk behöver.
Exakt.
Och framförallt att vi tar fram...
Som du säger, det är skitroligt.
All lycka till och jag hoppas verkligen...
Jag önskar er all lycka till och allt gott.
Tack för att du var med i podden.
Tack för att jag fick vara med i nära, så älskar podden.
Vi köpte en Google-annons själva för att testa lite hur det funkar.
Jag älskar, jag älskar.
Vi köpte en Google-annons.
Ja, det gick åt helvete.
Nej, vi ska inte hålla på med det där.